any ceasefire will come too late for
many here most of cherna have already
destroyed an unknown number of its
residents already dead
in the rubble here bodies are being
covered with blankets it's too
distressing to broadcast
someone carried away in a makeshift
stretcher
the city on russia's ruthless path from
belarus to kiev is now surrounded and
cut off
sky news has been sent these pictures to
show what that means for people trapped
here this is jana and her 10 year old
daughter polina
like most here a bomb shelter is now
their home
how do you comfort a child when this is
it
we have a big family here there are 17
people we can't go away and leave an 85
year old grandmother a mom or a brother
with a two-year-old
the little food left is being shared
around by local volunteers like xenia
the road barely visible through her
shattered windscreen
we managed to speak to her briefly after
she charged her phone on a generator
which is rationed to one hour a day
connection here is it's very bad when
we're hearing the bump sound
the person what we can do we can call
our relatives that live nearby to ask if
it's okay was it near to your home and
with the absence of the electricity we
didn't have the siren
we've lost xenia again just as she was
describing how desperate things have
become in china have it's also quite
clear that not only are they without
power
but they're without internet phone
signal as well and just almost any
ability to communicate with the outside
world it's little wonder chernohiv is
being called the next mario pole the
opposite end of the country but an
almost identical humanitarian
catastrophe
an azov unit that first began as a
far-right voluntary group still holds
the center of the city
one of its fighters eli speaks to me
from an undisclosed location in mariopol
putin's pretext
for invading ukraine for starting this
war was to denazify
the country was he talking about you me
and my comrades were accused as like
neo-nazis like uso nationally far-right
swings
white supremacist
uh and all the words like this putin
declaring that he is going to generify
the ukraine yes
or demilitarize and deny
clay
and right now they are bombing the
kindergarten
schools medical medical facilities
before eli signs off he says he's
confident they can hold mario paul but
without some hope of a break in fighting
it's unclear how long civilians can hold
on for sally lockwood sky news lev in
western ukraine